what is the best diet for performance
for training like what have you learned
through your career about this well i
think everybody is different
to me personally
i implement fasting
time restricted eating and and
prolonged fasting
what's the longest you've done so far
the longest i've done is five days i do
it quite often i do i do four times a
year i do
three to five days
uh water fast um
and i i liked it it helps me with
inflammation i think it boosts the
immune system
and uh that that's about the i read
papers about about this and i it helps
me also feel feel good it's kind of
very therapeutic
physical and mental just mental
mental and physical because when i eat
my when i break my fast and i sit at the
table with with other people
it doesn't matter what i eat if we all
eat the same thing i always tell them i
said my my food right now tastes better
than all of yours you know because i you
know i i have the this
thing that i i believe
sometimes you need to put yourself into
suffering to realize how
pleasurable something is
and uh
i uh tend
personally like diet-wise i eat whatever
i want
whenever i want i don't i no longer have
any problem with this
but if i would have a competition coming
up like
knowing that i what i know now about my
body i would orient myself
more towards an animal based diet
that's because i've tried different
things and that's the kind of diet that
i believe helped me
having less inflammation and feel better
in terms of performance for for for
doing something physical so high protein
high fat low carbs
well
this is is different between
animal-based diet and keto
i mean there's carbs there's a lot of
fruit uh i get a lot of the the the
carbs from the fruit okay uh a lot of
organs organs um
i know a little bit about paleontology
and in
the past
about you prehistoric human and i i know
that
um i know not only about that i know
because i i've traveled
certain places in the world i want to to
visit the maasai in africa the
hunter-gatherer tribe and i know that
when they kill an animal
they go for the organs first and i know
i pray most predatory animal they do the
same thing so organs i believe is
something that normally in in our
culture in the western part of the world
we don't really eat but it's something
that is very nutritious
have you been able to convince gordon to
try fasting
i always talk about diets
it's a different situation i think for
gordon because he's a heavyweight he
doesn't want to lose weight you know
when heavy weight the range of uh like
my range was like i was a welterweight
and middleweight but heavyweight it's
like some of the guys that you can p can
compete against their they might be 300
pounds so
if you lose weight
it's a it's a big problem you know what
i mean so it
and there are things that will work for
me that might not works for gordon you
know so we have to make his own
experience and and i told gordon
sometimes when everybody goes left try
to go right see how you feel with
certain things experiment
not not a topic uh
that's part of your optimization
optimal performance formula well uh what
i used to do before my stomach issues
and for those of you listening who don't
know i had recurring staph infections in
and i took a bunch of oral antibiotics
and it just completely wiped out my
stomach so
i just was diagnosed i was misdiagnosed
as gastroparesis so for those of you
messaging me on instagram who are just
watching rogan asking me about my
gastroparesis that's not what i have
they misdiagnosed it and
i did some other tests and for four
years i didn't even know what it was
and then i got this uh i went to this
doctor in california who
diagnosed me with i have h pylori and
then a fungal and a bacterial overgrowth
of my small intestines so the issues in
the small intestines um so what i used
to do was i used to do like
seasons where i'd have a very clean
season when i was competing and i would
have a lower body weight and i would do
like an off season kind of like a
bodybuilder where i would eat a lot more
food and a little bit dirtier food and i
would have cheeseburgers and pizza at
night time to have the extra calories
but now i can't eat those foods because
they upset my stomach so now i pretty
much just try to eat whatever i can and
maintain the weight the best i can
based on how my stomach feels so right
now it's like
rice chicken
eggs fish
vegetables fruits
and pretty much nothing else like
anything hard to digest
uh anything spicy red meat
fast food all that's all that's hard for
me
which sucks because in texas
barbecue
and i mean this diet is really important
for you john i can tell um
like is it is that something you think
about for athletes at all again this is
part of the i've um to be honest with
you um i've never seen
any measurable
improvement in sports performance in
jiu-jitsu by change of diet
i do believe that diet is important for
longevity
in human beings and i do think it makes
a difference especially once you get
past the age of 40
with regards to longevity
uh for older athletes i do believe it
makes it some difference but my
observation is in athletes and
in their youth and working up into their
prime
i've seen athletes have the worst diets
god bless travis stevens but that guy
won an olympic silver medal basically on
mcdonald's and candy yeah um
george st pierre for 80 of your career
you were powered by mcdonald's and
coca-cola
alfredo that was my yeah
my meal of choice before a championship
fight uh gordon for him his youth was
just five guys hamburgers gary taunton
the same thing
i've worked with japanese judo players
who smoked a pack of cigarettes a day
and won olympic gold medals
i've worked with
russian wrestlers who just
ate
whatever was put in front of them and
their athletic performance was
outstanding
um i've worked with other guys who did
have what would be considered a very
clean diet and
their performance was no better than
anyone else on the mat so i've i've
never
i've never seen someone say okay i
changed my diet and because of that
there was a measurable
improvement in sports performance
another way to phrase it though is um i
have noticed with a lot of lead athletes
what they eat
they begin to believe that that
either is not a hindrance or it's
actually good like travis steve is an
example of somebody who eats shitty
because he believes
it's like it's like a power because
whenever he's traveling across the world
he can't rely on healthy good food to be
there so i'm going to eat shitty
so that that's that like my body knows
how to perform under whatever skittles
or whatever everybody's got mcdonald's
everywhere's got mcdonald's so that
makes like and they've convinced
themselves and you talk about russian
athletes a lot of them have very
strong beliefs about like this
a particular food being good for them
but there's no agreement among them
exactly there's no agreement yeah yeah
so belief is more important than the
actual diet yeah
sorry if i can
after
you know after a a night out when you
hang over
i think the best thing and i'm saying
this in all certain sincerity i think
the best thing to eat to me was like
like
cheeseburgers with it's we call that a
puts in back home because it's very fat
it's greasy so that so the next day
when you wake up i think you feel better
because it absorbed the algae there you
go
but you can train
my mom
my mom told me the same story once and
then i tried i was like i was hung over
for some party and uh i woke up i was
like probably i don't know 19 or 20 i
woke up and uh my mom's like yeah just
have it have a cheeseburger go go eat go
eat something greasy and i did and i was
like oh i feel kind of better now
i do not know the science the exact
science behind it but i i i always
notice and i don't know if it's placebo
but i always notice that if i if i'm
if i'm if i party hard and i've been
drinking a lot
if i don't eat before i go into bed if i
don't eat shitty food the next day will
wake up and feel worse than if i eat
shitty food i feel better i know it
sounds crazy i don't know why but it
works for me
yeah but it's also hard to do science on
extreme performers so the discussions
we're having is amongst the very
you know that this might not apply to a
general like recreational athlete but
for the elite i've just seen champions
in every kind of combat sport and i've
never seen a correlation between dietary
habit and performance in people under
the age of 30.
i do believe that diet is important for
longevity however and uh for that alone
it may well be worth investing time in
it but with regards sports performance
at least in jiu-jitsu i've never seen
any significant difference